hello and welcome to this video and the
funny funny opponent the real chess
explain who is that that's funny it's
funny I have no clue maybe I know this
person
92 not quite sure if check first or 92
[Music]
okay 97 so I'm going to castle not not
certain mid with the bishop here that
was a good good thing let's see
[Music]
maybe Bishop to g5 trying to provoke a
small weakness with age six
if he goes age six it should be more
difficult for him to play f6 okay f6 is
a bit difficult anyway without the light
squared bishop so maybe this was not a
real concern you know but again I think
this is this pin is a bit of an
annoyance from like so that's um not
terrible to do and now what do we play
here I can I wanted to just drop back
actually to e3 or maybe just to d2
Knight f5 I have Bishop d3 yeah not bad
taking is really no good no point now
there five I will just capture maybe
it's going knight c6 now
[Music]
okay some probably couldn't be 3 and
then we'll see one just ok I don't mind
dad
should be a little bit a little bit
better for me this position it's not a
lot but it is some it is rather
comfortable I think so um am I just
doubling you know I guess I'm just
doubling who why is that possible even
or does he just want to trade here
like what is he doing here rook takes g6
is hanging maybe he wants to take no
taking with the bishop I can take h6 oh
he has to take with the rook yeah now
this is really a different kind of
position now do I want to play rook e1
and switch attention to the e pawn or
not
that's that's not clear to me if he
moves the ruqaiya Bishop takes a six
that's a nice little tactic maybe g5 is
a good move now for black I was thinking
about age form instead of rookie want to
prevent that but felt a bit slow
look not sure what I do I can so what is
this point he wants to probably
sacrifice on f3 and take on d4 that is
his idea mmm yeah this is why I cannot
play Bishop a6 bishop a6 rook f3 is
pretty awkward
and it's pretty awkward okay going to
switch attention to the opponent he can
take here I mean I think this is a an
exchange sacrifice that is probably
quite viable he decided otherwise
just putting pressure only six yes to do
something about it
probably rookie aid
[Music]
going to fix those pawns
I don't mind dad now my default point is
safe I have the idea night h2 2g forum
that was the idea behind H form it's
going to going to be annoying this is
going to take the square away from him
okay so g6 or e6 let's take this
[Music]
too many pawns
by far too many pawns
now to make Winston yeah there was a
tough game against the real chess
explained so let's see yeah this is
something that I analyzed in my book but
I don't quite remember if I had to check
first on 92 first the check first is
probably is better according to the
engineer right um okay it's it's
probably not a huge thing so I want to
look at the the little game here a
little bit provoking h6 was some just a
little once as we saw in the game that
g6 is week after f6 oh so this is still
fairly normal I guess and now we had to
know we had this ending I don't have to
do go to the ending word I thought I'm
better here some books e1 rook c8 rook
c2 and now we went there 6 yeah this is
now the interesting part so I took it
rook shakes and now you have to have to
think about this a little bit
I went rook e1 which is liked by the
comp I think it makes sense there to put
more attention out towards the e-file so
I went here here now important I cannot
do this this would be great I guess you
know
but after Bishop a6 he can take on f3
which is awful
I mean I saw that rook c6 is probably an
option but this is not it's not so great
you know I don't think this is any good
so it's better I think what I did just
put more support here and it's
interesting I think I mean he yeah he
could have considered this the problem
is that now both pawns are hanging and
he has a hard time to keep them he
really has a hard time to keep them so
that probably doesn't work he went
Knight a form went him rook e8 y and now
I don't know h4 I like this idea
preventing g5 of course Knight h2 is
also possible maybe it's better you know
it's not a bad move I'm just getting g5
out of the picture and here Knight age
two and somewhere here is probably the
moment where it's it dips from being
quite a bit better to winning or clearly
better king f7 and the engine wants to
go night to d8 simply go awful full
defensive mode I see him I would
probably played g3 for Nagi form here
Knight e3 threatening this also makes
some sense I mean this is a bit better
for me the weaknesses that he has easier
to attack but it's not decisive he
however it gets problematic g3 is good
preparing Nagi form immediate Knight g4
wasn't so convincing and I would get
three tricky I'm threatening to simply
win the rook basically and after this
he's he's losing the house
yeah and some inaccuracies but nothing
nothing special really after this is
just it's winning
it's basically winning for wine mmm now
I don't really like this line for black
I think if you want to play g6 which is
okay I would strongly prefer to play at
play to play d5 in this position and
play this kind of thing I would prefer
that to the to the game position okay
guys thanks for watching